[Music]
oh I was uh sent down from Washington DC
to see about these
murders H see see what about
him see who's doing
it you a
detective you Pinkerton what are you no
sir I was a Texas Ranger I'm now at the
federal government it's called Bureau of
Investigation um
I tell you what if you if you got
questions if you got questions uh I'll
go talk to the sheriff you can probably
tell you what you need to know oh yes
sir I have I I talked to him but I'm
here to speak with Molly Burkhart who
whose sisters and mother is dead yeah
Molly yeah know she's she's my she's my
wife they told me he was he was going
going with Matt Williams for a
time you talk too
much oh I don't talk too
much just thinking who I got to beat in
this horse race that's
all I didn't realize this was a
race I don't care for watching
horses well I'm a different kind of
horse H FY
what was
that that's how you are I don't know
what you said but it must have been
Indian for handsome
[Music]
devil
fore
shows itself to you that Bill Smith
didn't take the proper care of many the
way he could have to have her sick and
die take her head rights and a
land that or would should go to her
sister as your wife well he's taking
money that by right you go to
Molly the mother
Lizzy she's not in good shape she won't
last most soay don't live past
50 well the SE women die with how El
they suffer from illness you have to
make it the head rats come to
you you
see it's supposed to be a suicide you
dumbbell you didn't tell him to leave
the gun I don't know why I told him to
leave the gun I told him him to leave
the gun just like you told him I don't
know why he didn't I don't know why I
told him just like you told him you told
him to do it in the front of the head
and why did he do it in the back of the
head it's so simple the front is the
front the back is the back you has to
make it look like he done himself it
just looks like murder it's not supposed
to be that way you hear her I told him
the front of the head I said the front
of the head just like this just like you
told me I I promise you I promise you I
swear on my children I swear on my
children
K and don't swear on your children makes
you look foolish well I ain't I ain't
foolish cuz
I whose land is
this my
land
well well well our war hero has arrived
you made a good choice coming back here
say your definest wealthiest and most
beautiful people on God's Earth out
smart
everybody they have the same who gets
the
oil son I got a question you like women
that's my
weakness well we mix these families
together and that estate money flows the
right direction it'll come to us
show Mei that's how you are I don't know
what you said but it must have been
Indian for handsome
[Music]
devil why did you come
here I work with my uncle you scared of
him oh he's a he's the nicest man in the
world the old sieg their time is over
we got to take back control of our
home I was sent down from Washington DC
to see about these
murders we have so many deaths we've
lost count this just bad luck seems more
like an epidemic than bad luck to
me those SES Dying by the enemy do not
let them die
alone evil surrounds my
heart
you going to pick a
side I don't even know if you loved me
anymore of course I love you and kill
these men who killed my
family did your wife say who she was
most afraid
[Applause]
of don't do something you're going to
regret for the rest of your
life
[Music]
I ain't got nothing but
regret well well our war hero has
arrived killers of the flower moon was a
series of murders of oage men and women
to BU them at the discovery of oil on
their land the oage reign of terror was
a fascinating piece of American History
I was drawn to the idea to tell this
terribly tragic story that was never
brought to national attention Marty
obsessed with telling the story with the
most honesty that he possibly could one
of the key things was that it was drawn
to this world friendship and love
existed with latent extortion
exploitation and
murder when this money started coming we
should have known it came with something
else in our film Ernest develops a
relationship with Molly Burkhart I don't
know what she said but must have been
Indian for handsome devil Ernest was
encouraged to marry her by his Uncle
Bill hail in order to get her family
shares in the oil profit hail was a very
enigmatic presence in oage country he
definitely represented somebody that
wanted to take advantage of the
situation at all costs their time is
over there was a need to tell this story
from Martin scorsi there was something
intrinsic in him to do this story
Justice there's a Sinister nature of the
murders of the O people expecting a
miracle to make all this go away you
know they don't happen anymore I wanted
to do justice to the
oage so that the audience feels the
immensity of the
[Music]
tragedy